the napstack problem is a classic
optimization problem in computer science
it's often used to help teach dynamic
programming and greedy algorithms this
is an important problem to understand
especially if you plan on interviewing
soon for a programming job in this
course Gavin long will explain the
problem and show how to craft an
efficient solution using c-sharp Gavin
has created many popular courses for our
Channel and he's also a free code Camp
team member let's start learning hi
everyone I'm Gavin long
look I'm in trouble
I've recently been asked to leave my
apartment by my landlord
he says the neighbors have been
complaining about me causing noise
pollution
[Music]
thank you
the bottom line is the police are on
their way
to forcibly remove me
so I need to grab as much stuff as
possible and cram it into the snap sack
here
and leave as fast as possible the
problem is I've got a lot of stuff
so which items do I take with me
I need to take the most valuable items
so that I can come up with the money for
a deposit for a new apartment
but I can only realistically take a few
items
in the snap sack I don't even really
know what a knapsack is
so I guess this is my knapsack okay
it's kind of a rucksack knapsack
whatever it's a sack so the bottom line
is I have a knapsack with a finite
capacity which means I can only take a
few items with me
so I need a way to fit as much value as
possible into my knapsack
this is called the knapsack problem
luckily I've been kicked out of a few
apartments in my time
so I'm very familiar with the knapsack
problem
so
I have a solution to the knapsack
problem which I'm going to share with
you before the police come and cart me
away let's get into this video
in this video we are going to create an
algorithm using C sharp to solve the
famous zero one knapsack problem
let me briefly describe the problem
so we have a number of items in this
case four items
each item has an Associated weight and
value
so for example the first item weighs 8
kgs and has a value of fifty dollars the
second item weighs 2 kgs and has a value
of a hundred and fifty dollars
the third item weighs 6 kgs and has a
value of 210 dollars and the fourth item
weighs 1 kg and has a value of thirty
dollars
the problem is
we are trying to decide which items to
include within a container that can only
hold a certain amount of weight I.E the
container has a fixed capacity
so in this example our container will
only be able to hold 10 kilograms of
weight
so this is called the knapsack problem
but in this video I'll refer to a
container in place of a literal knapsack
we are trying to maximize the total
value that can be included within our
container
our code needs to consider each of the
relevant items and decide as it were if
the considered item must be included in
the container which can be represented
by a value of one or the considered item
must not be included within the
container
which could be represented by a zero
when we first look at this problem it
looks really difficult
if our code is considering each item and
making the decision as it were to
include or exclude the item
the total number of potential Solutions
is 2 to the power of n in this case 2 to
the power of four
because we are dealing with four items
so the time it takes to solve the
problem can be expressed in Big O
notation as Big O of 2 to the power of n
time
in this video we'll demonstrate that by
using dynamic programming we can solve
this problem in Big O of n times W time
n denotes the number of considered items
and W denotes the maximum amount of
weight that our container can hold
if you would like to read more detail on
Big O notation I've included an
appropriate link below in the
description
so we are going to go through the code
to solve the zero one knapsack problem
step by step to ensure that we
understand how the relevant algorithm
works
so basically the problem is we need to
choose the items where the sum of their
values gives us the greatest amount of
value when compared to the other
possible combinations of items that can
be included within our container so this
is an optimization problem that we need
to solve
for the purposes of this video we are
going to keep this problem really simple
we have a container that can fit items
that weigh less than or equal to 10 kgs
if the sum of the weight proposed as it
were for a potential solution is greater
than 10 kgs this combination of items
will not work we cannot take all of
those items because their combined
weight exceeds the 10 kg limit
so we need to include the items where
their combined weights do not exceed 10
kgs and the sum of the value of the
items that we wish to include in the
container is greater when compared to
the other possible combinations of items
that can be carried within our container
the problem is drastically simplified in
this example
if however we were to scale up the
problem where for example we have a
large shipping container and potentially
hundreds of items this would take most
human beings too long to calculate in a
time frame that could be deemed as
efficient
so this is where our algorithm becomes
essential
in for example shipping this type of
algorithm that we are about to implement
would run on a daily basis
we are going to use the bottom up
approach to dynamic programming to
implement the relevant algorithm to
solve our problem
this is in contrast to the top-down
approach
we could write our algorithm using the
top-down approach but we can avoid
writing recursive code by using the
bottom up approach
the approach to writing our algorithm
will involve a strategy called
memoization
very basically memoization ensures that
a function doesn't run for the same
inputs more than once by keeping a
record of the results for the given
inputs
let's briefly look at a depiction of how
the algorithm processes each item in
relation to the capacity of the
container the algorithm appropriately
considers each item's relevant data IE
weight and value each row denotes a
considered item
each column denotes the container's
capacity which grows as it were by a
value of one until the final value is
reached which is the capacity of our
container in this case 10.
the algorithm traverses each row from
left to right
for each cell in the table or each
position in the two-dimensional array
the algorithm appropriately evaluates
the weight and value of each considered
item in relation to the currently
considered capacity of the container
the algorithm then appropriately
computes the maximum value that can be
included in the container depending on
the considered data the computed value
is then recorded
at the appropriate position in the
two-dimensional array the relevant
two-dimensional array used for
memoization is depicted by our table
here
this is so that we can visualize how the
algorithm progresses and calculates the
relevant values
our algorithm will repeat the relevant
computational pattern until it arrives
at the final result which will be
recorded in the bottom right cell of the
table here or position 4 comma 10 of the
two-dimensional array used for
memoization the final result is the
maximized value of the items included in
the container
right let's write the code for our
algorithm
let's create a.net core console
application within Visual Studio
so let's write the pertinent details of
the relevant items and the container
involved in this particular scenario in
a comment at the top of the main method
we are going to store the detail of each
item's weight and value appropriately
within two separate arrays
so let's first create a one-dimensional
array named weights and add the relevant
weights of our items appropriately to
the weights array
let's create another one-dimensional
array named values and appropriately add
the values associated with each of our
items to the values array
I briefly mentioned the technique of
memorization earlier
so let's create a two-dimensional array
named data this array will enable us to
keep a record of essential values that
are computed as the execution of the
algorithm progresses
let's define an integer constant named n
that stores the number of relevant items
let's define the capacity of our
container so in this example our
container can hold a maximum weight of
10 kgs
let's create two for Loops an outer for
Loop and a nested or inner for Loop
the outer for Loop Loops through n
number of items which in this example is
a value of 4. each increment of the
inner for Loop denotes the weight that
can be held within the container at a
particular point in the execution of our
algorithm
so for example at increment 3 of the
inner for Loop
the algorithm will consider whether an
item can be included within the
container if the container can only hold
a weight of 3 kgs
when the increment is 4 for the inner
loop the algorithm will consider whether
an item can be included within the
container if the container can hold a
weight of 4 kgs and so on until the
incremented value of the inner loop hits
the Max Capacity which is a value of 10.
at which point the inner loop is exited
so here we have a table that depicts the
two-dimensional array we have named data
as discussed the data array is used to
store the results of computed values
which are appropriately recorded as the
algorithm progresses towards a
conclusion
this represents the two-dimensional
array that we have named data in our
code
So within the inner for Loop we need to
implement code that will appropriately
compute the values of the items that can
be included in the container at
appropriate points in the execution of
our algorithm the computed values are
then inserted at appropriate positions
within the two-dimensional data array
so firstly we need to write code that
evaluates the value of the item num
variable that represents an item in our
example so if the item num variables
value is 0 code to insert the value of 0
into the appropriate position in the
data array must be executed so if you
look at our table you can see that these
cells in the top row will all contain
the value of zero
considering zero item or zero capacity
for the container may seem redundant but
having these values within the data
array is essential to the working of our
algorithm this will become clear as the
video progresses if the item number
variables value at this point is not
zero our code must evaluate the value
stored in the capacity variable
so let's write the code that must
execute if either the item num variable
is zero or the capacity variable is zero
all we are doing here in this line of
code is recording a value of zero at
appropriate positions in our
two-dimensional array then if neither
the item num variable is zero or the
capacity variable is zero we need to
write code that makes another evaluation
so we can implement the relevant
evaluation code using an else if
statement like this
so here we are saying with this else if
condition if the weight of the
considered item is less than or equal to
the considered capacity I.E the maximum
allowable weight for items to be held
within the container at this point to
the execution of the code
we need to make a specific computation
before storing the relevant computed
value at the appropriate position in the
data array
so if the else if condition returns true
we need to use a formula to compute a
value before storing the value at the
appropriate position within the data
array
so let's take a quick look at the
formula
we can use C Sharps math.max static
method to implement the relevant formula
so the first argument that we need to
pass into the max method can be computed
like this
the second argument is as follows
the max method simply Returns the
greater value of the two arguments
passed to it
then we can write code to record the
value returned from the formula in the
appropriate position in our
two-dimensional data array like this
so if the conditions in the if and the
else if statement both return false we
need code to execute that inserts the
values stored in the cell directly above
the considered cell as it were at the
appropriate position in the data array
so to do this we must write this line of
code within the else block
and that's it that is the code
implementation for our algorithm
then we can write codes to Output the
final results to the screen the final
result is found at position n comma Max
Capacity so position 4 comma 10 in our
data array
let's run the code
and you can see that we are presented
with the correct answer the result is
the value of 390.
we can include the Drone the Monitor and
the kettle within our container which
gives us the value of 390 dollars so
let's go through the execution of our
algorithm in more detail so we can get a
clear understanding of what is going on
during the execution of the algorithm
so for the first row in our table all of
the cells will be set to zero because at
the points of execution of our algorithm
pertinent to these cells in the top row
the item num variable is equal to zero
so the code in the if block will execute
so we can fill in zero for the top row
in our table remember this depiction
represents the two-dimensional data
array that we are using for memoization
in our algorithm so now let's consider
the data associated with the first cell
in the second row
which maps to position one comma zero in
our data array
our algorithm at this point is
considering relevant data for the first
item which in our example is the
microwave
the considered capacity is equal to zero
so the value for the first cell in the
second row will be zero
then for the second cell on the second
row the considered capacity is one and
the item's weight the microwave's weight
is eight
so the if condition returns false and
the else if condition also returns false
if we look at the condition in the else
if statement
the weight of the microwave is greater
than the considered capacity of the
container in the elsif condition
and so the else if condition returns
false so this means that the code in the
else block will execute
so in this case we can insert the values
stored in the cell directly above the
cell that is currently being considered
as it were
into the cell
the cell that we have just considered
this depiction of course analogously
represents the appropriate value being
recorded at an appropriate position in
the two-dimensional data array
you can see that the code within the
else block implements this functionality
if you think about it in Practical terms
at this point in the execution of the
algorithm the code is considering if the
microwave which has a weight of 8 kgs
can be stored in the container when it
has a capacity to hold 1 kg of weight
this is of course not possible so by
recording zero at this point we know
that no item can be stored in the
container at this point
so this same logic applies until we
reach a capacity of 8. so let's record
zero up until the capacity is equal to
eight so when the container can hold 8
kgs of weight
capacity is equal to eight this means at
this point we can include the microwave
in the container because as discussed
the microwave has a weight of 8 kgs
the relevant condition can read as if
the weight of the currently considered
item is less than or equal to the
currently considered capacity run the
formula I.E the code within the elseif
block
so the else if condition returns true
because the weight of the considered
item is equal to the currently
considered capacity which is a capacity
that can hold 8 kgs so let's look at the
formula that runs to calculate the value
that will be recorded at the appropriate
position in the data array
so the algorithm at this point evaluates
using C Sharp's Max method which of two
values passes arguments to the max
method is greater the greater value of
the two is returned from the max method
so let's get the values that will be
plugged into the formula I.E the values
for the two relevant arguments that will
be appropriately passed to the max
method
let's look at the first argument so here
we are considering the microwave the
microwave has a value of 50. so we can
plug 50 into the formula here
then in order to get the value for the
first argument passed into the max
method we must add the value stored at
this position in the data array to the
value of the microwave I.E the currently
considered item
so let's get the value stored in the
data array at position 0 which is the
currently considered item number 1 minus
1.
comma the current considered capacity 8
minus the weight of the currently
considered item which is also eight
so we add the value stored at position 0
comma zero in the data array
to the value of the microwave which is a
value of 50
so we pass 50 as our first argument into
the max method
the second argument can be found at
position 0 comma 8 in the data array
which as you can see in our table is
zero so obviously the greatest value
between 50 and 0 is 50. so the max
method returns 50 and our code runs that
stores the value of 50 at the
appropriate position in the data array
so when the considered capacity is nine
the considered capacity is greater than
the weight of the considered item the
microwave which is 8 kgs so the code
that we have just examined also applies
for when item num equals 1 and capacity
equals nine so we can record 50 at the
appropriate point in the table
representing that this value has just
been recorded at its counterpart
position in the data array
the same code is also run when the code
considers the microwave which weighs 8
kgs against the capacity which can hold
10 kgs so let's record 50 at the
appropriate position in our table next
the code execution moves on to consider
the second item the Drone in this case
so the incremented value in the outer
loop item num will be 2. the inner loop
will evaluate each capacity
consideration from 0 to 10 for item two
incrementing the capacity by one with
each iteration of the inner loop
so at zero capacity of course we need to
include a value of zero here
when the considered capacity for our
container can hold one kilogram the
Drone has a greater weight than one
kilogram the Drone weighs 2 kilograms so
the code in the else block is executed
so let's record this value at the
appropriate position in our table then
the code considers a capacity for our
container where it can hold 2 kgs our
drone weighs 2 kgs which means the Drone
can be included in the container
so the code within the else if block is
executed so let's plug in the relevant
values into our formula so the first
argument passed to the math.max method
is the value of the Drone which is 150
plus a value of zero the second argument
is zero so of course 150 is greater than
zero so let's record the value of 150 at
the appropriate position in our table
the same values are processed by the
formula in the elsif block until the
capacity reaches a value of 8. I.E where
the code evaluates the container's
capacity where it can hold 8 kgs
each considered capacity from 2 to 7 for
when the Drone is considered has
resulted in our formula processing the
same values
however the values that will be plugged
into our formula will be different when
the capacity is 8. so let's
appropriately fill in the values up till
when the capacity is 8.
so when the capacity is eight the first
argument passed into the max method is
the value of the Drone 150 plus zero
found at this position in the data array
the second argument passed into the max
method is the value of the microwave 50.
so obviously 150 is greater than 50. so
here we record the value of the Drone
150.
when we consider the scenario presented
to us with the next iteration of the
inner loop I.E when the capacity is 9 we
need to record 150 once again this is
the value returned from our formula
implemented in the else if block
however when we consider the scenario
presented to us with the final iteration
of the inner loop for the currently
considered item IE when the capacity is
equal to 10. at this point we can
include both the microwave which weighs
8 kgs and the Drone which weighs 2 kgs
within our container because at this
point our code is considering a capacity
of 10 and our code is considering the
second item the Drone so here you can
see that the first argument is the
result of a calculation of the value of
the microwave plus the value of the
Drone which equals 200. the value of the
second argument is the value of the
microwave 50.
so 200 is obviously greater than 50 so
200 is returned from the max method
which means 200 is recorded at the
appropriate position within the data
array
at this point our code has recorded all
relevant values in the data array
regarding the microwave and the Drone
these items have now been considered
against all relevant capacity
considerations so the next increment for
the Outer Loop executes and the next
item the monitor will be considered
against each relevant capacity
so our code now considers the third item
the item number variable defined in the
outer loop is now equal to three
three represents the monitor the monitor
weighs 6 kgs and has a value of 210.
so at position 0 in the fourth row zero
must be recorded because the value
stored in the capacity variable is zero
so the code in the if block is executed
so in the capacity variable is equal to
one code in the else block is executed
because neither the capacity or item num
variable is equal to zero and the weight
of the monitor which is 6 KGS is greater
than the currently considered capacity
one so this means the value in the cell
directly above the position that is
being considered as it were must be
appropriately inserted into our table at
the appropriate position
the cell that we have just considered
so now the capacity is equal to 2. we
can see here that the value directly
above the considered position as it were
is 150 which is the value of the Drone
the code within the else block is
executed and a value of 150 is filled in
at the considered position
so the code within the else block will
repeat until the capacity variable is
equal to 6. which means if the container
was empty and had the capacity to store
a maximum of 6 kgs that the monitor
could be included in the container let's
appropriately fill in the values in our
table until the capacity equals to 6.
at this point the weight of the
considered item is the same as the value
of the capacity variable so the code in
the else if block is executed so let's
plug in the relevant values into the
formula so the first argument passed
into the max method will be the value of
the monitor 210 plus 0 which gives us a
value of 210.
the second argument passed into the max
method will be a value of 150 the value
of the Drone
210 is obviously greater than 150 so 210
will be stored at the appropriate
position in the data array here
the same value is appropriately recorded
for the scenario that is presented to us
in the subsequent iteration of the inner
loop
I.E when the capacity variable equals to
seven
so we can record 210 here
so when the capacity is equal to eight
the values that are plugged into our
formula are different to the values
passed into the formula when the
capacity was six or seven
so let's plug in the appropriate values
into the max method the first argument
has a value of 210
plus 150 which equals to 360. the second
argument is 150 so 360 is greater than
150 so let's fill in 360 here
so when the capacity variable equals to
nine
so the value of 360 is appropriately
recorded
let's plug in the appropriate values
into our formula when the capacity
variable reaches 10.
the first argument will be 210 the value
of the monitor plus 150 which is the
value of the Drone this gives us a value
of 360. the second argument comes from
the cell directly above the current cell
which is the value of the microwave 50
plus the value of the Drone 150 which
gives us a value of 200.
so 360 is obviously greater than 200 so
we can record 360 as the value in the
current cell
so we can now consider item four which
is the kettle the kettle has a value of
30 and weighs 1 kg
so in the first cell of this row we can
record a value of zero
then in the second cell where the
capacity value is one we can plug
relevant values into our formula to
compute the value that needs to be
recorded in the current cell
the kettle weighs 1 kg and the code is
considering a capacity of one
so the weight of the item equals to the
considered capacity so code within the
elseif block is executed
so the first argument passed into the
max method is the value of the
considered item so the value of the
kettle is thirty plus zero which gives
us a value of 30. the second argument
passed into the max method is the value
recorded above the current cell
which is a value of zero so we can
record 30 in the current cell
so in the capacity variable is equal to
2 we can pass in the value of the kettle
plus zero as the first argument into the
max method so here we pass in a value of
30. the second argument we need to pass
into the max method comes from the value
that resides in the cell directly above
the current cell which is the value of
the Drone 150.
so now when the capacity that we are
considering is three
the first argument's value will be 30
plus 150 which gives us 180 so that is
the value of the kettle plus the value
of the Drone
the second argument will be the value of
the Drone 150.
so of course 180 is greater than one
hundred and fifty so let's record 180
here
the next values we need to record are
derived from the same computation as the
one made when the capacity equals to
three until the capacity value reaches
6. so let's fill in the value of 180
appropriately until the capacity is 6.
so let's plug the values into our
formula for when the capacity variable
is equal to 6. so the first argument
that we need to pass into the max method
is the value of the kettle plus the
value of the Drone which gives us a
value of 180.
so we can pass 180 as the first argument
to the max method
as always the second argument that we
need to pass into our Max method comes
from the cell directly above the current
cell
this cell contains the value of the
monitor so 210 is obviously greater than
180 so we can record 210 in the current
cell
when a capacity of 7 is considered the
first argument passed to the max method
is the value of the kettle plus the
value of the monitor which gives us a
value of 240.
240 is greater than 210 so we can record
240 here
when a capacity of 8 is considered the
first argument passed into the max
method is the value of the kettle plus
the value of the monitor which gives us
a value of 240 when compared to the
value directly above the considered
position as it were which is 360
360 is obviously greater than 240 so 360
is returned from the max method and
appropriately recorded within the data
array
when the capacity of 9 is considered the
first argument passed into the max
method is the value of the kettle plus
the value of the monitor plus the value
of the Drone which gives us a value of
390.
When comparing the value of the Drone
plus the value of the monitor which
gives us a value of 360 to the value of
390 of course 390 is greater than 360.
so we can record the value of 390 here
the final considered position as it were
involves the same calculation as when
the capacity was equal to 9. so we can
record the value of 390 here
this is our final result
we have maximized the value of our
container with a value of 390.
and you can see how this algorithm works
when we look at the results in the table
the maximum value is being calculated
for every scenario until the final
capacity and number of items has been
considered
so if our container could only
accommodate a maximum weight of 6 kgs
and we were only considering the
following items the microwave the Drone
and the monitor we must only include the
monitor in our container to maximize our
value we can see what the value will be
if we look at our results in our table
here at this position
if we were considering those same three
items and our container could only hold
a maximum of 8 kgs we would include the
Monitor and the Drone within our
container
which would give us a value of 360
dollars we can see this in our results
here at position 3 comma 8 in our data
array
if we were only considering the Drone
and the microwave and our container
could hold a maximum of 8 kgs we would
only include the Drone in our container
to maximize our value
so as you can see in our results when we
are considering all four items and our
container can hold a maximum weight of
10 kgs we must include the Drone the
Monitor and the kettle to maximize the
value in our container this gives us the
value of 390 dollars
using the bottom-up approach to dynamic
programming we were able to calculate
this value in Big O of n times W time
complexity
n represents the number of items
considered and W represents the capacity
of our container the capacity is the
amount of weight that the container is
able to hold
so let's now write the code that will
use the data accumulated by the
algorithm we have just written
to tell us which items need to be
included in our container to achieve the
maximum value calculated by the
algorithm that we have just written
before we write the code for this
let's neaten up the existing code a bit
so we can put the code for the algorithm
in its own function like this
the values that Define the problem can
be passed into this function from the
calling code
which will be code implemented in the
main method
the function of course Returns the
result computed by our algorithm that we
have implemented to solve the zero one
knapsack problem
let's run the code
great
so let's create a new function that will
output the inclusion or exclusion status
for each of the items considered in our
application
you can see here we have a parameter
which is a string array named item names
so we need to pass in an array
containing the names of the items that
are relevant to our problem into this
parameter
so let's go to the main method Define a
one-dimensional string array and
appropriately add the names of the
relevant items to the array
the appropriate details of the items
that are excluded from the container
will be outputted with a red background
color
the appropriate details for the items
that are included in the container will
be outputted with a green background
color
so in the method that runs the algorithm
that accumulates the relevant data in
the data array the algorithm started
from position 0 comma zero in the data
array and worked from left to right for
each row in the two-dimensional array
named data Computing relevant values and
recording those values at the
appropriate positions in the data array
when the algorithm completed the final
result could be found at position n that
defines the number of items relevance to
the problem comma Max Capacity
that defines the maximum weight that the
container can hold the container's
capacity
so the final result can be found at
position four comma 10 of our data array
in contrast to the way the algorithm
worked the code that we are going to
write here will work backwards from the
position of the final result IE position
4 comma 10 until all relevant data has
been considered and all relevant data
has been outputted
so firstly let's initialize two
variables
let's set a variable named I to the
value that will be passed as an argument
to the parameter named n n denotes the
number of items relevant to a particular
problem
let's set a variable named J to the
value that will be passed as an argument
to the parameter named Max Capacity the
Max Capacity parameter denotes the
maximum weight that the container can
hold
let's create a while loop that
terminates when either I or J is equal
to zero
so the while loop will continue to
execute while I is greater than 0 and J
is greater than zero
the loop will terminate when either I or
J is equal to zero
So within the while loop let's include
an if condition that evaluates whether
the value at position I comma J the
considered item is equal to the value at
position I minus 1 comma J
if the compared values in this condition
are equal code must execute to Output
the details of the considered item with
a background color that is red
indicating that the item is excluded
from the container
we'll write the codes to change the
background color of the text accordingly
in a bit
conversely when the if condition is
false code must run that outputs text
denoting that the considered item is
included in the container this will be
indicated by giving the relevant text a
green background
so at the position immediately after the
if else code codes to decrement the I
variable by a value of 1 must be
implemented
so we are looping backwards through the
items in the data array
after code is run in the case when an
item is deemed to be included in the
container I.E within the else block here
we must update the value of J by
subtracting the weight of the considered
item from the current value of J
so the code within the while loop will
repeat until either J is equal to 0 or I
is equal to zero
so that is the logic for the code that
outputs text denoting items included in
the container and the items excluded
from the container
let's write a reusable function that
outputs text with appropriate background
colors a red background denotes an item
that is excluded from the container
a green background denotes an item
included within the container
so let's first write an enum that
contains three list items
let's name these items normal success
and danger respectively
let's write a method named write text to
screen
this method contains two parameters so
the logic for this method simply changes
the color for the outputted text based
on the argument passed into the second
parameter
so for our purposes here if the item is
included in the container the text is
white and the background color is green
if the item is excluded from the
container the text is white and the
background color is red
so we can now use our right text to
screen method appropriately in our code
let's run the code
excellent